[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANIL DHAWAN: Thank
you for joining us.
I know it's the last
session of the day.
So thank you for hanging on.
It's going to be awesome talk.
Let me introduce myself.
My name is Anil Dhawan.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Cloud Launcher.
And this is--
VILLE AIKAS: And
I'm Ville Aikas.
I'm a software engineer
from Seattle working
on Deployment Manager and a
couple of other Cloud config
things.
ANIL DHAWAN: So what we're
going to talk about today
is this concept of no more
dead software deployments.
I think we all know that
deploying software is already
hard enough.
Anyone disagree?
Oh, got one.
Couple dissenters.
We should talk.
Deploying software's
already hard enough,
but it turns out when
you move into cloud,
deploying your infrastructure
can often be harder.
And so what we're
going to do today
is talk about some
of the philosophies
that have emerged over time,
especially when it comes
to cloud, to make this easier.
And we're going to show
you some of the tools we've
built on Google Cloud Platform
that you can use to implement
those philosophies to make sure
that you're no longer deploying
dead software.
And then finally,
we're going to show
you some of the improvements
that we've done to the Google
Cloud Launcher product
to integrate and tie it
all together.
So for the first
time in cloud, you
have this unprecedented
ability to spin up
a whole host of resources,
from virtual machines,
to firewalls, to
disks, in one zone,
across multiple zones
around the world.
And that's fantastic.
And what happens is when you
get these powerful tools that
let you spin up these resources
in a matter of minutes,
is you tend to use it a lot.
You no longer are
constrained or confined
to plugging in ethernet cables
and managing on data center.
So you're now trying
different things.
You might be experimenting
with a staging
cluster in one environment.
You might be ramping
up a production
cluster in a different zone.
And that's exciting.
And it leads to
complex architectures,
but it also gives you some
great benefits, like agility.
You can finally take an
idea, put it into practice,
see if it works.
And if it doesn't, tear it down.
Not a lot of cost to it.
So the flexibility
you get is fantastic.
But as Spider-Man was
told, with all that power
comes a great sense
of responsibility.
So great.
You've spun up all
of these resources.
And you've SSH'd
into those machines.
And you've tuned
that kernel parameter
to make sure the IOPS
are going to be great.
But now when you want to
move to a larger system,
or scale down, or replicate
that setup, what do you do?
And so the default state is
what we call dead software.
And dead software comes
about because you've
lost control of what you did.
You've created these
unique snowflakes.
And they were great
when they were there,
but you no longer know
how to get back to it.
And what this means
is if you're not
going to have a way to get
back into that configuration
repeatably, you're
going to be vulnerable
because your software is
going to go out of date.
And you're going to get things
like configuration drift.
Because what you
had in your mind
is not what's running
in production.
Well, as you can
imagine, some people
have tried to solve
these problems.
And there are tools that do so.
But they're not a
whole lot better
in terms of solving a problem.
And I think what they lead
to is potentially something
worse than dead software.
And that is zombie software.
What these tools
try to do is they
try to patch a
running environment
to try to keep it up to date.
In concept, that's great.
But we all know the
reality is when you're
patching a running
system, you're
never going to be able to
make it work 100% of the time.
Well, when it fails, it's
really difficult to roll back.
It's equivalent to trying
to change the tires on a car
while it's running.
It's something you probably
wouldn't want to do.
So great.
So we've seen this.
We've seen this kind of model
happen in the on-prem world.
And when you move into
cloud, this problem
becomes exacerbated.
So there's got to be a
better solution, right?
Well, it turns out there is.
And it's actually
quite fascinating.
In the last few
years, this pattern
has emerged around
immutable infrastructure.
And if you saw the
Spinnaker talk today,
you know exactly what
I'm talking about.
And the goal of
immutable infrastructure
is to say, hey, let's no
longer change the tires
while the car's running.
Let's instead take
all the components
that comprise your
application, bundle them up
into one immutable image.
And you can do this through
the notion of a bakery.
And this whole process is
co-developed in the industry.
Externally, we've seen
folks like Spinnaker,
by Netflix, but also
internally at Google,
we've been doing these
patterns ourselves
for several years with Borg,
Borg config, and Midas.
So this is great.
Once you have an immutable
software package,
you have an atomic unit
that you know is good,
and you can trust it.
But that's only
part of the battle.
You've got this atomic
unit, but now you
want to make sure that you
can repeatably deploy it
in a multitude of environments.
There aren't many tools that
can do that really well.
And that's what we're going to
talk to you about today, which
is how do you implement
immutable infrastructure
on Google Cloud Platform?
We're going to show you
our tool of implementing
this philosophy.
It's called Deployment Manager.
And we're going to walk
through a set of examples
of how to get a quick VM up and
running, and then showing you
some more complexity in
building it up over time.
So what we want with
configuration and management
of infrastructure
is a few things.
Kind of a very high level.
One is you want
repeatable deployments.
You want to know that
the code you're running
is going to match the
infrastructure you
have in mind.
Next is you want to be
able to take that same code
and reproduce it in different
environments as you scale.
And finally, but perhaps
most importantly,
you want to single
tool and model
to describe and
deploy these things.
You don't want to have to change
what you do because you're now
deploying Google infrastructure
versus your own resources
or a third party's resources.
And this is really where
Deployment Manager comes in.
So what is Deployment Manager?
Deployment Manager is our
tool in Google Cloud Platform
to create repeatable,
idempotent deployments.
It's got a simple YAML-based--
so human readable-- description
language, with Jinja
and Python code behind.
So it's extremely flexible.
And as I said before, it can
configure any GCP resource
type.
So you're no longer
constrained to just VMs.
We can do Kubernetes, AppEngine,
IP addresses, firewalls,
the whole range.
And we've got a great glcoud
command line built in.
What Deployment Manager gives
you is resource configuration
that you can treat
like source code.
You can version control it.
You can share it.
You can understand the
evolution over time.
And it uses these declarative
templates described in YAML.
And what those give you are
these repeatable infrastructure
deployments that you use on
that gcloud command line.
All of these things
put together,
these templates and the
command line integration,
allows you to think at a much
higher level of abstraction.
And in fact, as
we'll show you today,
you can start describing
parts of your architecture
as components, and start
using those and consuming
those components with higher
level building blocks.
All of this put
together gives you
what we call living
software deployments.
And so I'm going to
turn it over to Ville
who's going to show us
Deployment Manager in action.
Can we switch over to the demo?
VILLE AIKAS: Thanks, Anil.
So I'm going to
go ahead and talk
a little bit about very basic
things from the beginning.
We're all faced with
very simple things
like, how do I get my code
up and running in the cloud?
So there's a couple of ways
that you can do this today.
As Anil mentioned, you can go
and go out there in the bakery
and you can say, hey,
give me an image.
Whether it's a docker image
or whether it's a VM image
doesn't really matter.
For this example, I'm going
to be using VM images just
to keep things simple.
But once you have
that nicely big image,
you want to go and get it
up and running in the cloud.
And we certainly have solutions
for you to do this today.
You can go up there
on the cloud console
and you can go ahead
and turn some knobs
and slide some sliders
and out pops a VM for you.
And that's all great.
But then if you want
to go and redo that,
say a week, two, five
weeks later, you come back
and you're like, what
was it that I do?
I can't remember.
You can also do this from
the gcloud compute tool.
You can go in
there and say, hey,
I would like to go in
and spin me up a VM,
give it some command line
flags, and out pops a VM.
But you're kind of faced
with the same problem again.
The only thing that
you do have now
is maybe a command line
history, so you can hopefully
spin back up to it.
But we can probably do a
little bit better on that.
So I'm going to go
ahead and show you
how we can do this with the
Deployment Manager today.
So for the people
on Manager, you
go ahead and create
a configuration file.
It's a YAML-based file.
It looks like this.
It's very simple.
At the top, you say, I would
like to create some resources.
Well, that's nice.
Then you say what you
would like to create
in the form of a list.
So in this case,
I want to create
just a single VM called myvm.
I give it a type,
because we need
to know what type
you're creating.
This one is a VM, but
as Anil mentioned,
it could be just as well
a network, load balancer,
firewall, whatever it is.
And then we give it
the list of properties.
So the properties should
look familiar to you
if you have used
compute in the past.
There's nothing new here.
They all look and feel the
same because they are the same.
Because the API is
mapped one to one
with being the underlying
resource and what
the Deployment
Manager talks about.
OK?
So I'll give it a
zone, a machine type.
This case, f1-micro
because it's a demo.
I give it a disk.
I want to boot off of
persistent disk using a source
image that I have baked
already for this demo.
It's creatively
called nodejsstatic,
because I'm not very
good with naming.
And then I have
network interface.
I would like to
say, please give me
a network interface
that I can actually
access from the internet.
I say, give me a NATic
interface, one to one.
That means that it's going to
give me an external IP address.
So using a gcloud command
line tool, I can say,
Mr. DM Manager, please
give me a deployment.
And I give it a pointer
to my YAML file.
Oh, I also have
to give it a name.
So let's call it myvm.
OK.
So while that's going
on, the nice thing
is that because we
were able to go ahead,
once we created a YAML
file where we put all
these properties
into it, I can now
go ahead and take
that file, and I
can put it into source control.
I can put it in my GitHub.
I can keep track of what
changes on that file
and when does it change, who
made that change, in why was it
made.
That's a really
powerful concept.
And for this simple
case, it doesn't really
matter that much, but
you could also do things
like, unit tests, right?
I could come in
there and make sure
that I know that I have a step
in there that actually says,
I'm about to deploy something.
How do I know that
I'm actually deploying
something that makes sense?
And also, remember
that all the properties
that I created or
defined in that
file, we're mapping one to
one to my underlying APIs,
so I can go ahead and use
this tool today without having
to understand any
new technologies
or any new languages.
I can just go and take the
properties that I know and love
from the Google Cloud
and just go and create
my list of resources.
And say, please give me
some stuff in the cloud.
So let's look at this happy
little VM we just created.
Let's do this first.
I'm just using
gcloud compute tool,
if you used this from
the command line.
And I'm asking it to describe
what my VM looks like.
Zone.
OK.
So there's a couple of
things that we really
only care about in this one.
There's a lot of stuff here,
but it was nice that it actually
got the machine type for me.
So I wanted an f1-micro,
so it created me that.
That's nice.
And it also gave me
an external IP address
that I can then go and
say curl against it.
And it prints, surprisingly,
Hello world, right?
So at this point, we can now
go ahead and take this file
and we can go and put it in as
part of any kind of pipeline
that I have.
And I can go and tear this
thing up and down all day long.
I can come back two weeks later.
I can give it to
Anil and I can say,
hey, Anil, would you like a VM?
ANIL DHAWAN: I would love a VM.
OK, Ville, that's great.
But we're Google.
If I wanted to change
something, let's say
I wanted a larger
instance, or maybe I
wanted to change a zone,
are you telling them
that the best practice
is to copy the file,
and make the changes, and
check it into source code,
and now have two copies?
That doesn't sound
the right thing.
VILLE AIKAS: Yeah, you
don't have to copy it.
You can cut and paste.
Um.
ANIL DHAWAN: Fair enough.
VILLE AIKAS: OK, fair enough.
ANIL DHAWAN: For old school,
the [INAUDIBLE] is cool.
VILLE AIKAS: So, yeah.
So we can certainly
go and do that.
And we have to build in
some templating capabilities
in the Deployment Manager.
And I'm going to go
ahead and show you
a little bit how that would go.
So let's go ahead and say
that we want to go ahead
and run two stacks.
So if you have a
dev stack and a prod
stack, and I want to have a
VM running in both of those.
And again, I'm going to keep
these examples very, very
simple just so we can
all follow along and not
get cluttered by all
kinds of different config.
But in real world, things
will be more complex.
OK?
So we can come in to
my handy dandy Emacs.
And again, if we look at
this file, I templatize it.
And the way we do
templates is either
by using Jinja or using Python.
For these examples,
I'm using Jinja,
but we have plenty
of examples in Python
as well if that is
what you want to do.
Notice that the file
looks very, very similar
to what we had before.
So at the top, we
have resources,
because I would like
to create resources.
I have a list of them.
In this case, I only
have, again, one.
And for the name, I have
just parameterized this.
I can now say, OK, when you
go and use this template,
you need to specify a name.
And I will use that
name to name my VM.
I'm still using the same type
for my compute.v1.instance.
And then I have, again,
the list of properties.
Zone doesn't change because
you didn't ask for that.
But here is where we introduce
a little bit of that magic
here, where we can
come in and say, OK, I
would like to go ahead and add
a new property, and a little bit
of program [INAUDIBLE] ability.
So that I can come
in and say, OK,
if you'd like to create
the prod environment,
we'll give you a super
beefy n1-standard-2.
Not really, but you
know, it's better
than an f1-micro for this case.
Otherwise, just create
me an f-1 micro.
And then the other
parameter that I added
is because we probably want
to go ahead and run two
versions of the different code.
I want to go and continuously
deploy to my DevStack,
so I'm going to go and
parameterize my source image so
that it's going to go
ahead and boot that VM off
of that source image,
instead of always hardcoding.
Because you probably
don't want to run
the same version of the code
in the same environment.
And everything else is the same.
And then to use this, I am
going to go ahead, and again,
create a config file that
looks pretty much the same
as it did before, with
a couple of exceptions.
One of them is it has a section
at the top called imports.
So think about that like
your import statement, where
you say, I would like to use
a different kind of a type.
And I give it the name.
It's my vm_template.jinja.
And then I give it
a list of resources.
So in this case, the
resources, again,
it looks and feels the same.
It's got a name,
type, and properties.
But for my type, now
I'm using this new type
that I have just created.
OK?
So the type is the template
that I just created.
A new type, user-defined type,
with only three properties.
So I can go and
say, OK, the name.
Right?
If you remember, that
was the name that
is given the underlying VM.
And an environment.
That was an optional
field, but in this case,
we specify it because we
want to go and run it.
And then I'm going to go and
give it a different source
image.
So to get this up
and running, I'm just
going to go ahead and
point to my second file
that I just created,
the single_vm_2.
And I'm going to give it
a different deployment
name, because I'm going to
create a prod environment.
And while that's going, let's
go back and look a little bit
about my template here.
And the one thing
you might point out
is, OK, this is
really nice, but it's
going to be very tricky
to go and remember
how do I use this template,
and what are the properties
that I have.
And while you could certainly
go in and use your grep powers
and everything else to find
out the things you care about,
we have introduced a concept
of schema-- not scratch.
There we go.
--where we have a
JSON schema that you
can attach to each one of
these templates and types
that describes what it
is that this type does.
So I can look it
and say, info, OK.
It's a single VM template.
Great.
It's written by me.
And there's a description
that you can use.
And then the version, so you
can keep track of versioning,
that you can add in addition
to your source control.
And then you have a
section that says, here
are the required
parameters that you
must give when you want to
construct one of these types.
So in this case, I
only require for you
to go and give me name
and a source image
so I know what to boot.
Right?
And if you remember, there
was an if-else clause,
so I didn't make the
environment required.
So it's not as part
of the required list.
But all the available
properties are then
listed in a section
called properties.
And each one of
the properties is
described by what the
name of the property is.
In this case, name, a source
image, and an environment,
as well as the type,
because this could be an int
or whatever else it is.
And it also has a description.
So you can easily
inspect this file
and look at and say, ah,
what does this thing do?
What can you do for me?
Oh, yay.
It finished.
OK.
So now we have a
prodfrontend, right?
So let's go and look
at that a little bit.
Again, I'm just going to
go and describe that VM.
I'm a great typer.
OK.
So the machine came
up, which is nice.
And then, if we look
at it, we can see now
that the machine image has been
changed to our beefy production
instance.
That's nice.
And again, if I just look at the
external map that was given it,
I can go ahead and ping that
and see that it's my production
environment.
So at this point, I have been
able to go ahead and take
this thing, again,
put it in GitHub,
and I can go ahead,
in case like this,
now you can start to
see where you're like,
OK, actually, this one I might
want to go ahead and write
some unit tests against it.
So if I go and specify a
property as, say, a prod
environment, I actually
want to go and see
this kind of a
machine spinning up.
ANIL DHAWAN: That's cool.
That's pretty cool.
But I know you're a
copy and paste guy,
but like a lot of people in the
audience, I use micro services.
So on VM, two VMs
is kind of cute,
but talk to me about
micro services.
VILLE AIKAS: Micro services.
This guy's never happy.
OK.
So that's great.
So DM really lends
itself-- Deployment Manager
really lends itself very
well to micro service,
because if you start thinking
about now the abstractions
you can create.
The example that I created
before was very, very simple.
It's a simple VM.
And that's nice.
But if you think
about it that it
can create any kind of a
resource for you underneath,
it could be a highly scaled,
load balanced, service endpoint
for you that you connect to.
So to go and demonstrate
that concept,
I'm going to go
ahead and use, again,
my trusty old VM template Jinja.
And I'm going to go ahead
and run MongoDB on that.
So again, the first resource
in my list doesn't change.
It's-- well, we
accepted the name.
But, you know, I'm
again using my type
here that I created before.
I'm going to call in MongoDB.
And I booted off
my MongoDB image.
However, if you notice, I am
adding a secondary resource
that I'm creating as part of
this type that I'm running.
I am creating a service
registry endpoint here
that actually allows
me to go and solve
the second problem that I have
when I run micro services.
So the first part is I'm
going to nicely define them,
and saying, this is
my micro service.
And then I'm going to be able
to go ahead and decouple that
from the consumers of
that particular service.
So in this case,
what I'm doing is
I am actually producing
a service endpoint
that my customers or consumers
of this service can use.
So again, it is just
another GCP resource,
so I just specify a type
differently from a VM,
because I'm not creating a VM.
And I give it some properties.
And the properties,
in this case,
I am just giving it the
address of the MongoDB above.
But if you notice, I'm using a
syntax with the dollar ref sign
here.
And that actually allows
me to go ahead and start
creating orchestration.
So Deployment Manager
is going to look
at this list of resources
and it's going to say ah,
I can create a MongoDB
because it doesn't really
depend on anything.
But when it gets down
to the MongoDP endpoint,
it's going to say,
oh, I need to go ahead
and wait before creating this
service registry endpoint
because it depends on Mongo DB.
So DM is going to go
ahead and spin up the VM.
And then it's going
to go and go back
into that network
interface of that MongoDB
and pull that out,
and then stuff it
in the service registry.
So because this
is a GCP resource,
it actually means that it
behaves like a first class
citizen.
You can list your services.
You can say, hey,
what are my services?
I might have dev services,
I might have prod services,
staging service, and so forth.
I can create them and delete
them and everything else.
But the other nice thing that it
does behind the scenes for you
is that it also creates a DNS
entry for you in your GCE DNS.
So that means that without you
having to run your own naming
and discovery
services, this endpoint
will be visible
through you in the DNS,
and you can just use this
from your VMs and Kubernetes
clusters, and all of everything.
And you can also restrict the
visibility of this endpoint
so that it's maybe only
visible to your dev network,
or test network, or whatnot.
So let's go ahead
and spin that up.
OK.
So while that's going on
and it's creating that,
so let's go and just step back
again and think about the value
that we are able to do now.
Because we are able to now be
able to decouple the production
and consumption of these
services by using the service
registry.
That's a really powerful
concept in itself.
The second powerful
concept that we have here
is by building
these abstractions,
I can go ahead and very easily
and with a very high degree
of confidence be able
to come in and say,
when I need to bring
up my DevStack,
no matter how complex it is--
because I have treated it
as source code, right.
It's checked in somewhere.
It's got tests
associated with it.
Every time I just go and
spin up these stacks,
I know that they're
going to come up.
It also allows me to go and
nicely document these things.
With the JSON schema,
we saw those things.
Right?
So it was very clear and easy
to go and see how it's used
and so forth.
So there it is.
It now comes back
and says, thank you.
I created you two resources
like you asked me to.
So it created a MongoDB and it
also created a MongoDB endpoint
for me.
So let's go and see
what this looks like.
So in this case, I'm just going
to go and SSH into the machine
that I created in the first
case, my little single VM.
And I'll just grab this
name endpoint here.
So if you look at this
name that we created here,
the nice thing about this
name is that it is carved out
into its own namespace so
that I can easily go and say,
what's the MongoDB enpoint?
It's scoped to a project.
And it's also separate
from your other DNS entries
so that there's no
kind of collisions
between what other
people develop or add
in there or anything else.
So let me just grab
this from here.
And I'm running in
the VM that I created
that had no knowledge of
my handy dandy MongoDB
even existing.
I can now come in and I can
see it from my single VM,
creating a nice decoupling
within my services.
Can we go back to the slides?
OK.
So let's go all the
way back and think
about what we just started.
So we started with a very
simple declarative YAML format.
It was really nice and easy.
We could just go
ahead and come in
and look at all the properties
that we already know.
If I know VMs, I can go and
come in and create my VMs
using concepts I already know.
OK.
And the second thing
we added on top
of that was, OK, that's great,
but how do I parameterize that?
How do I create my own types?
How do I add
programming in there?
So we saw a little bit of
that using Jinja templates.
Again, we also support Python.
But these examples
are using Jinja.
And we created new types.
So this is a really
powerful concept,
because now what I can do
is, instead of thinking
about my cloud resources
as just resources,
I can start composing the
resources that I want to
and put them into GitHub,
and describe and declare
what it is that they actually
do, how do they look like.
I can test them.
And I can really start creating
all of my configuration
as code.
It should be treated
just like code.
You'll be happier.
And then I also
showed you guys how
we can go ahead and start
putting micro services,
build on top of
those abstractions
by using the service
registry as a loose coupling
mechanism between the
producers of the service
and the consumers
of the service.
And so at this point, you
might say, OK, that was great.
You showed me a couple of
VMs and everything else,
but in reality, things are
really, really complex.
Right?
And I agree with you.
They definitely
are very complex.
So if you think about this
is a pretty standard kind
of a pattern that we see
all the time, which is,
I might have highly
available, autoscaled load
balance thingamajigger
running, right?
Let's call it my front end.
How would I go and do something
like this in the cloud?
It's pretty complex.
Well, the nice thing is
that by us showing you
how you can go ahead and create
and reuse some of these types,
we've also created a bunch of
these best patterns and best
practices that you
should be able to use
right out of the gate.
And we have many of these
examples in our GitHub
that we'll show you
in just a second.
And the second thing is that,
again, in the production,
you probably don't
want to go ahead
and-- even though you can
reliably go ahead and deploy
your production architecture
up and down at will,
you probably don't want
to go and tear down
your entire infrastructure.
Because your customers might
not be happy doing that.
So we have a couple
of things that
allow us to go ahead and update
parts of our infrastructure,
like a rolling updater.
And can I get back to my machine
just for a moment, please?
Oh, that's big.
OK.
So what I have done here
is deployed ahead of time
exactly the picture
that I just showed you.
So I have a nextdemo.
And then what I have is I
have created a new high level
type called ha-service.
And you can see it
right there on the top.
It says oh, you
have a ha-service.
That's great.
And your ha-service is
composed of three things.
It's got a service stamped
out into two zones,
but it's just two
instances of the same type.
And then on the bottom, we
have an lb load balancer.
So now when you
look at the picture
that we just showed
you, and we look
at the actual resources
that were created,
you can do one to one
mapping and say, oh yeah,
that's what I deployed.
That's nice.
And then if you drill down
to each one of these things,
like let's say our
l3 load balancer,
you can start to see
that at this level,
I have a new type where I
have taken three primitive GCP
resources.
I have wrapped them in
the one lb3 load balancer,
and I have that hierarchy
information right here.
So I can come in and I
can see the application,
how it's built.
And then if I look
at my service,
I can see that I
have this updater
that I mentioned before.
It allows you to take a
managed instance group
and give it a couple of
images, and it'll handle
the rolling update for you.
So in this case, we have
updated from Ubuntu into Santos.
And it also has
an instance group,
and it has an order
scaler, and so forth.
So this is ha-service
type it's very powerful,
because it basically
takes in maybe about five
or six properties.
It takes some order
scaling parameters.
Give me the lower bound.
Give me the upper bound.
Give me the pointer
to your code.
And give me the zones
you want to run in.
OK?
And it just spins it up for you.
Then you come back
to it later and you
can say, oh, I would like
to update my running code.
You can just give it a new
image and the rolling updater
will update that
for you for the zone
that-- however you want
to go and configure it.
Typically, you'd probably
do one zone at a time,
but however you want to do that.
So let's go back to the slides.
So we have quite
a few people that
have been using Deployment
Manager for a while.
And some of them
really like it a lot.
So it's not just me.
So here are some of
our customer quotes
that have been
using and building
things with the Deployment
Manager for quite a while.
And we are very happy
that they are happy,
because that's nice to hear.
ANIL DHAWAN: So Deployment
Manager is great.
And Ville described to
you how you can use it
for your own infrastructure.
But when it comes to building
solutions in the real world,
you're often just using
your own software,
you're often using software
from other sources.
How many of you use
third party software
today in your own environments?
Pretty much everyone.
Exactly.
And this is where Google
Cloud Launcher comes in.
Just a quick show of
hands-- ho many of you
have used Launcher already?
OK, so quite a few.
For those of you that
haven't, just a quick overview
of what Launcher is.
Launcher's the marketplace
inside Google Cloud Platform
for you to get started
running third party
software and services on GCP.
It's integrated directly
into the developer's console,
and I'll show you
that in just a moment.
And it's not just about getting
simple VMs up and running.
We actually have very
sophisticated solution
configurations which
we'll show you.
And what that allows
you to do is not just
kick the tires on software, but
actually run it in production.
And especially for
large enterprises,
one of the big benefits here
is you get a single bill.
So you're using third party
services and software,
but it's all going on
your single Google bill.
So no more separate
POs just because you
want to run MongoDB.
We've grown quite a bit.
We have over 160
solutions from a variety
of great commercial partners.
You probably recognize most
of the names on here today.
And beyond solution
growth, we've
actually seen phenomenal
customer adoption.
Just over a year ago--
between a year ago and now,
we've kind of 4x'd.
We've grown 400%, which
is just outstanding.
And the customer feedback
has just been phenomenal.
We've been hearing
great feedback
around people being
able to deploy solutions
a lot faster now that
we have the ability
to give them third
party software directly
within the console.
And so I'm going to
go ahead and show
you Cloud Launcher in
action and demonstrate
some of the integrations we've
done with Deployment Manager.
So we're on the demo machine.
So I'm going to switch in here.
OK.
So here we are in our Google
Cloud Platform Developer's
console.
And Cloud Launcher is
now integrated directly
into the menu.
So you just click here.
You can find Google Cloud
Launcher right there.
This takes you
directly to our store
front, which allows you to
browse all of the solutions
we have.
They're categorized.
You can also search
through them.
And so I'm going to go ahead
and find, let's say, a MongoDB.
So I see one here.
You can quickly learn about what
it is, what it can do for you.
We highlight the key
aspects that you care about,
like for example, what version
of Mongo is it running?
And how much is it
going to cost me
in the specified configuration?
And we actually
expose the pricing
in a very detailed fashion.
So you actually know
what you're paying
for at the resource level.
And we even show you your
sustained usage discount,
which I know you all love
running on Google Cloud
Platform.
So that's great.
Now we'll take a
look at what it looks
like to deploy MongoDB
solution on Google Cloud
Platform in the Launcher.
So I just click Launch.
And what you see is
not the same interface
that you would get when
you're trying to deploy a VM.
What you get is, instead,
something very tailored.
Tailored specifically
to deploy Mongo.
How many of you have
deployed Mongo yourselves?
How many of you
enjoyed that process?
Nobody.
Not a single hand.
Exactly.
Totally relate to
your experience.
This is really where I think
the power of the Launcher
really shines.
What we have here and
we're going to show
you is how you can run
production configurations just
by a few clicks in a wizard.
So what we've done
here is we've exposed
some of the key
things you'd want
to configure for Mongo, namely
server nodes and arbiter nodes.
So what you can do is
you can choose your zone.
That's great.
And then you can choose
how may nodes you need.
And so let's say I
want stick with two.
And what we do is we have
intelligent defaults.
We sort of, over
our experiences,
know what makes sense to run
different types of software.
So in this case, we're
suggesting using a high mem 4
vCPU machine.
You can change that if you
don't like it, of course.
But we're going to
stick with that.
And since we're running
database software,
you may want the
extra performance
you get from running an SSD.
And last but not
least, you probably
want to control how much
storage you have attached.
So we allow you to
control that as well.
Well, in any MongoDB
configuration,
as you can see here,
you have your primary
and you have secondaries.
And then you also
have this arbiter.
Well, you want your primaries
and secondaries to be beefy,
but that arbiter's not
doing a whole lot of work.
All it's doing is kind of
being available for heartbeats
and doing some leader election.
And we've captured that
concept in our configuration.
So what does it mean for you?
That means that you're
not unnecessarily
paying extra just because
you need another machine.
We've instead suggested using an
f1-micro, the smallest instance
size, to run that arbiter.
I'll go ahead and click Deploy.
And what you're
going to get taken to
is a same experience
that Ville just showed,
namely Deployment Manager.
And so this week, we announced
that all of the packaged
software solutions
available in Cloud Launcher
are all built on
Deployment Manager.
And what that means
is you get access
to all the rich
resources and templates
that Ville just described,
along with all of the power.
So you can deploy once.
Bring it down, tweak some items.
And now get
repeatable deployments
that you can integrate with
the rest of your software
solutions.
So this might take a
little bit to deploy,
but I deployed one earlier
while I was watching
another one of the sessions.
I called it here gcp-next-mongo.
And the things I want
to highlight here
are, we're not just
giving you a deployment.
We're not just bringing
up an infrastructure.
What we're actually giving you
is a single pane of management
for that infrastructure.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, if you're running MongoDB,
you have these primaries
and you have this arbiter.
One of the first
things you want to do
after you deploy this
software is start using it.
And so what we've done
is we've bubbled up
the primary actions
directly on this page.
So for this MongoDB
solution, I see
that I can have a button
that's SSH-ing to the primary
and the server.
And this is taking
advantage of our cloud SSH
feature, which allow you to
not have to worry about keys.
Everyone-- there's
not a single person
who doesn't love this feature.
I know all of you relate to it.
So here we are.
Now we're in our machine
and this is the primary.
So out of those three
instances, we've
already shown you
how to get exactly
to where you want to be to
begin with, the primary.
And I'm going to show
you it running in action.
So I'm just going to
go Mongo local host.
And since this is a
replica set, there
are going to be multiple
nodes in the replica set.
So let's go ahead and
query the status of that.
And as you can see
here, the replica set
is set up the way we want.
We have, namely, a primary.
We have a secondary.
And then we have that arbiter.
And what we've done behind
the scenes, what I'm not
showing you, is SSH-ing
into every one of those VMs,
piping IP addresses
and configuration,
making sure each node
can talk to each other.
And you've seen this deployed
in just a matter of seconds
really.
And just a proof of that,
the deployment I kicked off
is actually up and running.
And we can do the same there.
Let's go back to
our slides here.
So hopefully, what
we just saw is
that Cloud Launcher is probably
the easiest way to get started,
especially running third
party software and services.
Not just kick the tires,
but you can actually
run it in production.
We've got a wide
variety of software,
so if you've used
Launcher in the past,
I encourage you to come back in.
We're constantly
adding new solutions.
And since it's directly
integrated developer's console,
what's great for you
as developers is you're
no more than a few clicks
away from deploying
amazing third party packages
whenever you need to.
You don't have to go
outside the console.
You don't have to futz with
anything outside of providers
or billing.
It's all integrated.
And last, but
certainly not least,
is all of our packet software
solutions, as I mentioned,
are now integrated directly
with Deployment Manager.
This gives you
full transparency.
If you messed up and didn't
like some configuration
we did for you, that's fine.
Download a template.
Tweak it.
If you want to compose with
what we did, go for it.
It's all available for you.
So wrapping up this
talk, a couple things
we want you to take away.
First, as we talked
about earlier,
is this notion of using
immutable infrastructure
with repeatable deployments.
It's going to
increase the chances
that it's just going to work.
Right?
You're going to go
from having deployments
that are snowflakes, things
that you can tweak once,
may never be able
to replicate again,
to something you can
stamp out repeatedly.
Deployment Manager,
as we've seen,
is our Google Cloud
Platform native tool
for implementing that pattern.
It can deploy
resources and images,
whether it's VM
images or containers.
And Cloud Launcher solutions
are a great way to get started,
but not just to kick the tires.
You can use them in
production and then
start composing more
sophisticated solutions,
because the solutions are now
based on Deployment Manager.
All of the demo code
Ville showed you today
is available at our
GitHub repository,
so I encourage you
to check it out.
And so putting
this all together,
hopefully you've
seen how we've moved
from a world of dead
software deployments
to living software deployments.
Thank you.
VILLE AIKAS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]